I now realize something I already knew
but I didn't have the guts to act on
which was that at any given time you're
really only going to get to throw your
all into one thing
and so why not throw like if you're
gonna do that like choose really wisely
[Music]
we uh we're in San Francisco we're
outside of San Francisco we're doing a a
live pod the first time in a while we're
in the studio what is this the music
studio is that what this is normally
music studio did the instruments Give It
Away uh all right people were asking
online they said they want us to do a
pod we already did my story it's the
second episode uh now we'll do one on
you all right let's do it so how old are
you now
good question uh 34.
um and you're from everywhere everywhere
where I was born in Oklahoma Believe It
or Not
Tulsa yeah uh Denver Texas China
Indonesia Australia San Francisco
yeah that's it and maybe a little bit of
London too two months and you're living
in Australia in pre-college or right
right College I studied abroad there and
then also after college I started a
company with a guy who a like kind of a
well-known entrepreneur in Australia and
that was pre-college that was after but
and when you went to college in Duke too
so you went from duke to Australia yes
and at Australia you did the sushi thing
no I did that I just add Duke like
that's what I started a few things in
Australia no no that was here and then
we moved to Denver because
um basically
you know like people move to Silicon
Valley because it's like that's the tech
Hub and like people moved to LA when
they want to be an actor if you want to
start a restaurant Denver is the place
to go so Chipotle started there the
first Chipotle started there Noodles and
Company started there Quiznos started
there Smashburger started there there's
like the seven biggest amounts of like
open-minded white people yeah people
love lunch
lunch is a really big deal there but
they uh like so all the talent the
people who know how to like pick
locations and like Roll Out restaurant
operations all this stuff they're all
still there so when it was like where
are we gonna start it was like uh
because Denver is kind of like a big
suburb like this is how dumb we were we
were like
we want to be the next Chipotle how do
you do that well where Chipotle start
and so literally we found the location
across the street from the original
Chipotle to open our restaurant that's a
great plan and so we were like yeah and
like I guess we'll just do the exact and
then we were like who rolled out their
real estate oh these two Brokers okay
we'll we'll go talk to them and then who
did their this okay we'll go talk to
them and that's basically that was our
whole plan um of like figuring out how
to start this restaurant and so we just
moved to Denver because and it was funny
my two co-founders my two two best
friends at the time Trevor and Dan
you're not really a co-founder of a of a
super restaurant yeah co-owner amazing
yeah yeah that's that's a good point
that should have been the signal one
that this is not a great idea it was
like founding what
like my my father-in-law owns a moving
company he doesn't call himself like the
founder of Creator yeah yeah he's just
the owner yeah that's fair so me and my
two friends were trying to eat sushi and
we basically started this thing and they
were like we were at Duke so they were
just trying to find a location near us
and I had gone I'd actually quit the
startup I didn't really tell people this
but I basically when I graduated I got a
really good job offer and it was 120 000
in Indonesia and so and my sister was
working at the place and the guy wanted
my sister was doing a good job so he was
like okay I'll hire you know we need
more the guy who ended up going went to
prison I went to prison so uh I take the
job and I'm like I tell my friends again
like stupid I was like I'm gonna go
learn a bunch here and then dudes when I
come back think about how smart I'll be
and they were just like okay I guess
we'll just keep working on it over here
like total jerk move I just like moved
and took this job
for like a mafia guy who like did like
junk bonds or what did he do no he just
he basically what he had done was he
he's like a drop out of second grade or
something like that so he's like he
basically didn't speak English so my
boss never spoke English to me
um only like broken words crazy guy like
um you walk into his office and there's
four uh like executive assistants or EAS
or secretaries or whatever and each of
them have a giant TV screen and it's
just his email because he can't read or
type and so they would say out loud his
email uh this person emailed you saying
this and he would just dictate he would
be pacing around he'd just say tell them
we're not doing the deal unless blah
blah and then one would be typing then
the next one would be like hey you got a
another email from this person there's
just four screens like that they were
just like the brain yeah he's just
talking out loud okay literally can't
read or write just like his hands and
then when p and so what he was doing was
what his his genius plan was he was like
he recognized this Arbitrage opportunity
that was illegal which is why he went to
jail which was that U.S companies wanted
to do business in Indonesia Indonesia is
like I don't know maybe the fifth
largest population in the world it's got
a ton of Natural Resources like coal and
they so Exxon Mobil uh BP all the
conical Philips they all wanted this
coal but if you go there and you try to
get the rights you go to the auction and
they're like uh actually that guy owns
it my cousin owns it and they're like
where was the process like yeah the
process was done in the middle of the
night you don't need to know about that
deal with it basically you got to bribe
somebody to get something so what he was
doing was he was like oh they want this
so I'll just go and bribe all the local
officials
get the pro I'll get the leases and then
I'll just sell it so he bought up for
two million dollars total like this huge
amount of coal and then he sold each
piece for 20 million and he amassed 500
million dollars over the course of like
three years just doing that and so when
but it's like liquid so he was liquid
Uber liquid like if you if you did
something if you like did good job with
the negotiation or meeting or contract
you'd come into work and he'd just hands
you keys to like a BMW or a Mercedes or
Rolls Royce and then you'd be like that
was your bonus like there's no set like
but did he have paperwork who's who's
name was on the title of the car yeah
everything's his like we lived in this
like Four Seasons Resort but it's his
apartment but you get to live there
everything he owned and then he owned it
under 72 shell companies so you'd be
like hey what's this name and then
there's like this one woman who owns the
file cabinet she's got all these
companies inside and so that's what this
guy's gig was and so he was basically he
was like I don't need to know he's like
he would just talk to Engineers a
technologist and be like what would you
do with this call he's like great
um then when when he'd get a like he had
like all these geologists on and he'd be
like do a survey or do a report that
says this is fit for that purpose and
they're like well it's kind of funny
he's like make it very fit and he's just
like basically fudged the whole thing
that's my impression what do you think
made him special he was just yeah and he
wasn't cheating like he was just like
playing that's how business is done in
Indonesia you don't get like that's how
the property process is done if you
don't want to do that you cannot play so
you think that he was playing by the
rules of the game by the unspoken Street
rules of of the game
on that part and then on top of that he
was like smart and ruthless so for
example I met him because he met my dad
my dad worked at BP for like 30 years
and my dad was known as an expert at
this one technology to get value out of
coal you do this process you turn cold
that's not that valuable into something
pretty valuable so he meets my dad he's
like tell me about this and my dad's
talking to him and my dad's like do you
understand like these things that I'm
saying he's like I understand that BP
will want my coal basically he's like I
understand that like companies will
believe this thing you're saying there's
a potential here that's all I need to
know
and my dad was like but like should we
test it or like he's like no no why
would we test it let them test it
they're buying it they can test it and
like they can see for themselves like
you know if it works it doesn't work why
would I add risk into this by like doing
this and my dad was just talking to me
and then my dad one day goes I think I
told the story before but he goes he's
like he's like I probably am like a top
five expert at this one cold like
technology in the world you know pretty
much nothing about coal
yet I've worked my whole career and I've
been making a hundred thousand hundred
fifty thousand two hundred thousand a
year and you're gonna make like 300 400
million this year you're gonna make more
money than me and I know more about this
than here he goes yeah of course and he
was just like he's like yes and um you
idiot yeah do you think that that's
relevant basically you just like so
matter of fact about it and so I was
like oh wow so my job when I worked
there was company comes in he doesn't
speak English so he needed an English
speaker to do a meeting and then he
would just do the pleasantries and the
food and the drinks and all that stuff
and like you know just like with a
translator make that work but he'd rely
on us to like go over the presentation
what was his name Cocos you're like all
right gentlemen Mr Cocos would like you
to feel welcomed here and let you know
that he's not here to play any games
yeah it won't be like Mr Cocos and these
two young women will now uh go to dinner
with you guys and I hope you have a
great night you know like because again
that's how business is done there is
like you go to karaoke I don't know if
you know about all this like Asian
cultures like you go to these karaoke
rooms and there's like why are there all
these cute girls here it's like bottle
surface at a club one of the prostitutes
or something or just I don't know I've
never like gotten that far into the the
Lion's Den but like there's something
going on like you know there's some
service or I don't know if it's just
flirtation or there's more I don't
really know but like all I know is this
guy was getting mad deals done using
this like workflower during the day I
love singing Don't Stop Believing yeah
I'm presenting at night they're singing
songs yeah and so that was that was a
wild experience for me so how long did
this guy go to jail for well he died in
jail he's dead so uh wow why do you
think I'm sharing all this because I'm
like less afraid now that like I've
never really talked about this how much
do you think it says for I think he got
like 20 years or something and he died a
few years he got cancer died he was a
nice guy he was not he was really good
to us he was really nice to us I mean I
think he was like again I asked this
before like he was not evil he was just
doing business by the way that that game
was done whoever was going to own that
land was going to do that he just
decided it'll be me and he got
fabulously rich off of it and all the
things that seem really crazy to me was
also like kind of standard practice in
India and in China about like how
business deals are done yeah you drink a
lot you go out to the bars you with the
with the clients and like you you know
yeah you you have to grease the the the
the guy who's doing the deal not
necessarily so that you can win but you
won't get it if you don't tip everybody
basically that's involved in the process
that's actually this that's the first
time of two times that you've buddied up
with a billionaire who says like here's
my playground you can run it so you the
sushi thing like it was only mildly it
wasn't a success it was not a success
though but you moved to San Francisco
and you got a job with Michael Birch
right that's right and who who was he at
the time he uh by the way I don't think
the uh hot wings are here would you mind
getting them uh so I I told you this
when I got here I was asking people I
was like yeah me and Sam are in person
we're gonna just hang out we're gonna
have a good conversation how do we make
how do we take advantage of the fact
that we're in person and two of the two
first two people I say they go get a
bunch of hot wings it'll make it
hilarious try to have the same
conversation
and I think there's milk yeah there's
not there's no sides
um so I moved to San Francisco pretty
quickly I'm like God this can't be it
like no dude it sucks every day I'm
waking up at five in the morning I'm
driving to like the [__] Fish Market
picking up the fresh tuna for the day of
job and like the business was actually
working like we did it as a cloud
kitchen and it was basically making
money I was like this can't be it
luckily at that time my dad had met a
guy in Australia who had sold his
company and in passing did your dad is
like just hooking it out a king he met
this guy and he was he was like in
passing he's like you know what are you
what do your kids do and he's like oh my
daughter does this and my son is doing
this like you know Sushi startup thing
you should should check it out there
they write this blog that's really
entertaining it's like I was we were
creating a word we had a WordPress blog
that was really just for our own
Amusement but like we used to do a lot
of stuff to make content that in our
mind was like somehow gonna help the
sushi thing it didn't help the sushi
thing at all but what it did do was
anybody who found that really got behind
us they like kind of started rooting for
us or they thought these guys are good
Hustlers they're entertaining blah blah
blah so this guy who had just sold his
company for like 450 million and he was
looking for his next thing to do
he had a non-compete uh with Curt with
the business he knew so he knew he
needed to do something new but he didn't
know what and he read our blog and he
was like oh yeah I want to do business
with you guys like so he flew us out to
Australia and we interviewed for a job
with him and he was like uh this guy
Nathan Mitchell so he's uh he's based in
Brisbane
and uh his family had a drilling company
sells the drilling company and so he
wanted to do business with my dad he
wanted to do business with us and he was
like okay let's put a team together and
let's do this like that's such a cool
way of saying that you just I want to do
business with you yeah well that's what
I told myself I don't know what he I
don't know what he wanted I can't put
words in his mouth but he um all right
here we go
[Laughter]
so there's three there's three flavors
there's like a a sweet spicy a spicy and
then what they called very very spicy
which one's a very very spicy one
I'm not touching that one you think it's
that one no yeah yeah the six and the
Buffalo all right uh buffalo in a minute
so
basically if we ever answer a question
poorly or something we gotta eat I don't
know I'll make up a game I'm gonna eat
them because I'm hungry
um so basically he's like all right
um
I got a bunch of like smart Engineers
but this will be so academic unless we
get some hustlers you guys are Hustlers
join me and let's make this happen and
give us a job offer I was just happy to
live in Australia so I was like great
I'll do this and so we started that
company together as a biotech company in
Australia as that goes on
it gets to a point that I thought was
you know like kind of the transition
point where it's like oh we signed this
deal it's like ready to like change
hands or whatever and I was like all
right I'm gonna move to Silicon Valley
because I don't know about sushi I don't
know about biotech but I know I like
this early stage stuff so I apply to two
jobs
stripe and then this place nobody ever
heard of called monkey Inferno
stripe would have been pretty sick it
was probably 30 employees at the time oh
my God so if I joined even as just like
what I was joining as like a Biz Dev
manager or something like that I
probably would have made like 10 or 20
million dollars if I just stayed there
you think 20. I think so yeah because I
I kind of I went back one day and I did
the math and I was like I don't know
there's a bunch of assumptions like will
you vest out would you get a promotion
like you know a bunch of things like
that but based on when it was like 20
2012 early 2012 at the time which like a
lot of people I tell people the story
about me and they're like oh you would
have gotten fired and I actually think
they're probably true in your case I
think you wouldn't have I think yeah I
would have played that game I like that
yeah I'm good at that because that [__]
was exciting and you seemed like you
would have gone I don't know those guys
but you seemed like you would have got
along great with them yeah like you're
you're more of a cowboy yeah like but I
think you legitimately would have made
tens of millions of dollars I think said
too uh but it all worked out in the end
like I have less than that but I was
able to like got myself into a position
where I was able to do more so basically
like either like self-development or
just like getting lucky with those
shares
um and not entirely lucky like I only
applied to stripe because I thought that
was going to be a winner but like it
still would have been lucky that it got
to be such a huge winner could you tell
early on that it was going to be a huge
winner
yeah I don't know why I think I was just
like at the time I was reading a lot of
Paul Graham essays I was looking at why
combinator companies within y combinator
those Founders I watched some of their
interviews I'm a big like you bet on the
person type of like you know the person
who builds all the value I never talked
to the founders I I basically I had one
interview with this guy Ben and um
he and I blew it like I had the
strongest warm introduction that guy's
Mentor was also my mentor and the mentor
thought so highly of me he was like how
did you blow are you just cocky no they
did a sell me this pen type of question
that's a [__] but it wasn't a pen he
was like he told me he's like I'm not
gonna do a sell me this pen type of
thing but I am but I'm gonna do sell me
this software and I was like okay what's
the software and he's like you pick you
pick it and so I'm like it's my first
job interview ever I've never
interviewed for a job and I go and I'm
like basically dating Angelina Jolie
like stripe is my first job interview
and I'm like not prepared at all and
he's like what's a piece of software
you're like I'm like uh I don't know
like um so I'm trying to think of what
software other people like rather than
what I like so I was like uh base camp
by 37 sequels I knew that was like a
popular those guys were popular so I
didn't even use it though and I didn't
use it though so I didn't know what to
say but now I'm pot committed I didn't
and I didn't want to admit that hey I
just picked random company that I don't
actually use like that didn't make any
sense either and so I'm like fumbling
and stumbling no the the way I got
messed up was I started to explain it
like I would I'd be like you know so
what I would say if I was selling this
yes
ring ring hello go you're selling this
thing to me now and I was like oh God
and I just dude I think that's something
way to interview someone by the way I
think that's I think those games are
stupid yeah I don't know like
I guess yeah I guess I would agree I
don't want to say it's stupid just
because I sucked at it like no that's
not a good reason the best way to the
best way I found interviewing someone is
I just want to know if I enjoy being
around you and the only way I'm gonna
judge if like you're qualified is by
just looking at your history
yeah that's that's fair like I just want
to see what you've done in the past and
I'm going to talk to your old co-workers
and then I'm just here to decide if like
this is a good culture fit I I heard of
uh somebody got this guy Kyle samini
he's like a VC he's he put out a post or
he put out some interview or whatever
where he said he's like yeah there's
only one way to apply to my firm uh I
don't look at any resumes or reference
call nothing he goes just take one of
our existing blog posts and write it
better like write a write a better blog
post than we have on our blog you could
take the same topic or a different topic
just write an amazing blog post and I
was actually like that's kind of a good
test as a good initial filter I would
still want to talk to the person but
like that's a really good idea because
when you see someone right you see how
they think yeah and so and how how good
they are at like how good they were
writing a Blog was actually a pretty
good test for a lot of things
um so so I'm kind of into that as a test
what was oh my God he's brought milk is
that milk or is it tinted glasses so it
almost makes it look like eggnog
should we uh should we start with uh
with the medium or you want to start
with the light yeah but do you want
Buffalo or sweet well that's the should
we go I want buffalo I don't want sweet
okay here's the Buffalo one we'll do
we'll start with the Buffalo the sweet
can be our like uh palette cleanser
nothing like eating on microphone by the
way yeah hot wings are the worst you
have any paper towels You're Gonna Hear
Me gnawing all right this is the hot
ones episode
of my first million
thank you
dude I'm doing no milk what brand I mean
what what restaurant
shout out to our sponsor Wing It
providing These Wings today
dude I used to live in an Asian
neighborhood here in San Francisco the
in the Chinese and like Hong Kong
restaurants would make hot wings they
are the worst at making those hot wings
because they put like too crazy it's too
breaded and they uh put like sticky [__]
on it you know what I'm saying you know
I don't know what that crap you know
that sauce that like I don't know what
you're talking about dude have you ever
had a like lunch or dinner at like one
of the Chinese restaurants on the Inner
Sunset yes like it's like their hot
wings are like breaded like fried
chicken but then dipped in like sticky
sauces yeah yeah that's what those are
gonna be I think that's I hate that
sticky [__] all the Chinese restaurants
I go to I was like I was like I don't
know what that sticky crap is but don't
give me that please like I want to know
also I went Wing in because I knew you
would not want a boneless wing yeah I'm
not an idiot I would have done boneless
dude because I'm such a domestic no this
is a barrel cat
you know the right way to eat these is
use well it's easier with the other ones
but you got to stick the whole thing in
your mouth and just pull it out
yeah that's like I've seen so many tick
tocks of that everyone who shows that is
fat 100 of people who have a strong
opinion about
how to eat buffalo wings are fat
let's go holiday time to eat what wings
this is good this one's not too spicy at
all
what was monkey Inferno when you applied
so I um
I apply and it's basically it's a
startup Studio or an idea lab I forgot
what they called themselves at the time
basically it was like
16 engineers
designer one designer
and then Michael and zochi Birch who
were the like the owners and the the
husband and wife couple that was married
they obviously sold a company for like
850 million dollars they sold bibo for
850 million
this is how you do it do it into the
camera
wow clean clean
[Laughter]
yeah it looks like you're having fun
over there
a mistake to just nibbling on the
outside it's all good for me
I like I like my
I like my my Wing Bones like I like my
women
clean
in your mouth
oh wow
uh yeah so my girlfriend was basically
like this guy's done what I want to do
so let me just go work with him again
like
how did Chipotle start I don't know or
how should we be successful like the
next Chipotle let's just go we're
probably starting to follow their
footsteps same thing I was like this guy
has built several tech companies like
maybe three or four companies that have
gotten millions of users
millions of dollars and one huge one for
850 million and when he sold that
company that company is considered I
read this article where they said here's
the top 10 worst Acquisitions of all
time number one was Mark Cuban's thing
where he sold to Yahoo for two or three
billion right number two is bibo which
sold to AOL for like 850 or or whatever
and when he was doing that deal he must
have seen the numbers and been like oh
Facebook's way better we have like three
weeks to get rid of this thing yeah he
told me that story basically he was like
yeah Facebook was just growing super
fast and they were just better like they
were just better at what they were doing
and he's like we were just getting
swamped with like we had all these like
spam bot problems and then we had uh
like you know this other problem and
then like VCS wanted us to make money
and this this is our you know I hired
this President she wanted to expand and
make money doing these like deals with
oh Eminem is doing a takeover of the
home page and like wow we made like half
a million dollars doing that he's like
but the case was a rapper
but they actually did have other stuff
like they started a reality TV show
called like I forgot what it's called
like Joanna or something yeah that ain't
gonna work but like at the time Myspace
was like Myspace was one model they were
like the media company they sold for 400
500 million bibo was looking at that was
like okay we could do that like
Hollywood yeah yeah you know big
advertising Big Marketing thing and
Facebook was like blue
website no ads just focused on photos
engagement growth like all that stuff
and they were just growing like crazy
because and they had a more controlled
growth because they were doing College
college first so they were able to like
not have all this like spam and all this
other problems because they were gated
by you had to have a University email
address for a while and he sells this
company and he has how much you think he
was worth after he sold well they owned
like 70 so public math but you know 70
of 850 and then half taxes to taxes yeah
to hundreds of millions of dollars
hundreds of millions of dollars and it
comes to America and he basically hires
like he was already in America the whole
time okay he was here he was in the
literally this part of the bay area oh I
didn't know that so he was here he buys
a place in San Francisco and he hires 10
engineers and then they're all just
working on crazy [__] they buy seven
condos smashes Down the Walls to create
one huge office and it was the same
office that the Beats by Dre headphones
were designed and stuff like that so
that was one part of the office the rest
were just condos and he builds he leaves
one as a condo that was there you saw
that the bedroom that was there and then
puts a bar in there he puts a like a
whole ping pong kitchen entertainment
area and then huge office space uh where
we all worked so day one I get off a
plane from Australia I come straight for
the airport to the office to interview
and I get there a little early and right
across the street was a Burlington Coat
Factory so I walked the hood I walked to
the Burlington Coat Factory and I'm just
standing there
with a suitcase yeah they're like
and then I walked across the street and
I ring the doorbell I'll go inside and
I'm just like wow and the walls were
mirrors that were one way so you could
if you were inside the restroom you were
looking at a mirror if you were outside
the restroom you could see into the
restroom or something like no the other
way if you're looking at it doesn't look
like a mirror if you're inside yeah the
non-weird way looked like people could
see you but they couldn't so they're
like this guy had a good sense of humor
and sense of style with different things
so I'm just like I don't know I've never
seen anything like this that place
probably has like
a few million dollars worth of
Furnishings yeah it was crazy that was a
crazy place
um
and then I interviewed them and it was
the easiest interview I ever had
most chill interview is just like tell
me your stories kind of amused with my
story and he's like a cheeky guy and
he's just he had already decided that's
what he told me later he's like you had
applied applied with this like website
resume where I was like oh oh why I'm
the guy for the job I wrote this email
and then I started sending them like
ideas for their current products I was
like hey um I checked out the flow for
this I think it could be improved here
in here so I was like trying to make an
impression I was I didn't do a job
search I did a job hunt I was like this
is the job I want I'm gonna Zone in on
it and I'm gonna go like hunt for that
and I'm gonna try to capture that job
that's exactly what I did too and so if
that had worked basically by the time I
got there he was already into interested
as long as I wasn't a weirdo I think I
wouldn't have blown it and uh so chill
and I got the job working under him and
then like six months later he was like
hey
um
you should run this thing basically and
you guys started uh three or two or
three products
um more that we did like maybe six or
seven two or three that were like it
some would only last a month some would
last what was the two years what was the
mo he said just all right here's two
million dollars a year or how much
budget did you have we had a business
that was already making about two
million dollars a year but it was
declining birthday alarm.com right
birthday alarm.com and then we it was
like a business one project was just
maintain it and then at one point as it
was just declining because it was like
you're just fixing bugs like let's turn
this around so we did a turnaround then
that got back up and that was a website
my aunt would pay you ten dollars a year
and you would be reminded when it was
someone's birthday yeah she'll never
forget Sammy's birthday and then when
it's Sammy's birthday if she's paying
the reminder is free if you want to send
a card
you pay the subscription
like 14 a year or something like that
and it made between two and three
million dollars all profit almost other
than hosting exactly
um and so that was the cash guy that
funded the whole lab and then on top of
that if we you know if we needed more
expenses they would just invest money
into it so I think it funded I think
they funded half and he put half uh just
cash and his his mandate was like
uh we don't do B2B
and we don't do real world like t-shirts
or Uber or things like that they don't
do like physical worlds of that from
bibo probably he was just like yeah like
whatever you got to pick a lane like
we're pretty broad like it could be any
idea but like of the Lanes let's not
let's do only consumer and let's do only
software how many Engineers did you have
there
like 16 ish 18. when I went there I was
like oh this is a tech billionaires
Country Club
that's what it felt like not even a
country close nobody else was there it's
just like his play it's like his man
cave yeah playground just like yeah man
cave is a better word because you had
like Old Mac computers as like uh art
yeah and you had like really nice actual
real art and like it was just like oh if
I'm a billionaire nerd in San Francisco
this is exactly what I would do as well
so instead of like owning like old
Ferraris he just hired 16 inches yeah
yeah those two he just didn't keep them
in the office oh he had those two yeah
uh and so all right so he had all the
he's got an island he's got cars he's
got you know his own projects he owns
his own hotel his own private do you
think he was happier than you did you
think he yeah sure do you think he was
happier for back then when he was a you
know billionaire he was probably in his
late 30s at that point maybe early 40s
40s yeah do you think he was happier
than you are now
he's definitely more at peace so I think
I'm pretty joyful like on a day-to-day
basis I'm kind of bouncing around and
he's more stoic than that like he's he
definitely has a good sense of humor and
laughs a bunch and that doesn't take
stuff too seriously I get I'm more
easily excitable so I'm excited about
random stuff anything I can get excited
about anything I probably still want to
prove yourself but I have this inner
not peace I'm not just at rest I'm like
trying to do something prove something
be something make something earn
something win something and like I he
just didn't have that that same because
of the acquisition because of that and I
think just wisdom like I think he saw
okay
you know his whole cohort of friends
mostly became super successful they were
they were the who's who of Silicon
Valley and so he told me once he was
because I was like I was like how come
you don't blog like I feel like all the
VCS are blogging at the time that was
like the big thing and I was like why
don't you he's like well I just don't
feel like I have anything like that
interesting to say
and I thought that was the funniest
answer because I was like
I could have heard him say I should I or
I do and then or he could have said no I
don't want to do that because of this
like I play the game this way instead
but it was so humble to just say
I just don't feel like I I have the like
if I don't have something interesting
contribute why would I just blog in your
face I would be rude dharmash shot uh
the founder of HubSpot he's you know
this billionaire guy who's like uber
successful he told me he goes yeah I'm
speaking at masters of scale Reed
Hoffman's thing his conference and uh he
was like yeah it's like um you know the
founders of stripe Bill Gates uh the CEO
of uber whatever like kind of the who's
who of all these big shot he's like I'm
so humbled and honored and I can't
believe like they're having me and I was
like I I said I go really can you really
not believe that like it seems like it
seems like pretty believable like you're
like uh like that seems like a very
believable thing there's evidence yeah
yeah like I I don't I don't like from an
outside perspective you're like a
billionaire your HubSpot at some I don't
I don't know what the cutoff of a
Fortune 500 is but like it's definitely
there or right around there you know at
times it's worth 20 to 30 billion
dollars and you made it I mean yeah I I
can't believe that you'd be there and
he's like well you know they're just uh
I'm just honored and I just and like I
uh you know I I cannot believe I'm
actually gonna be there and I was like
well I don't I don't even know what to
say that's just so hard for me to grasp
because from the outside you guys all
seem like the same thing yeah you know
what I mean totally uh but I thought
that was weird so you're this I'll give
you I'll give you an example of a way
where I saw that he was more at peace
like uh we had a product that was
launching and the Press was covering
techcrunchers covering it and
it was like oh sweet TechCrunch wants to
do an article and they sent to they they
sent over the draft or they sent over
like some bullet points or whatever no
no it was good but it was like um
they had said something that was like
more than it was like they had said 200
000 and actually it was 20 000 users or
whatever like whatever some number was
inflated
and I was like so happy I was like yes
this is great like they're just gonna
say a great thing about us even greater
than reality like but I was a sort of
like I wasn't gonna correct the record
like that's on them right you know like
I in my mind I was like this is a good
thing they're over giving us credit yeah
they're giving us more credit than we
deserve and he was like he's like well
we should just correct it so it's the
real number and I was like but then it's
like worse for us right he's like yeah
but like you know
we don't need to
we don't need to do that
and that was the first one then the
second one he was uh he was talking
about uh I think he had a bad experience
with his VCS at bibo and when and we had
some VCS interested in funding us at
blab and he was just like he's sharing
some stories and he had told me he was
like um
I was like do you think that they'll
follow through he's like Oh They'll
follow through like silica Valley he's
like
he's like Isaac I would never not follow
through he's like if I commit and even
there's not a contract and then I
realized that oh it's not going to work
out for I committed I'm in he's like
because this this is a town where you
play the game for like 30 years with the
same people
and if you make a move that's like
self-advantageous now
um like your reputation is worth more
than whatever that's whatever that is
that was the idea that was his approach
and like actually I've there's many
examples of people who are like sure my
reputation is bad but like I banked 40
million or 80 million or 100 there's
like all these examples of that in
Silicon Valley too and you you know what
like
they won in their way but when he's like
he was just so high integrity
and I was not as high integrity and I
realized the reason why I was 100
Integrity is not because I'm evil not
because I'm a bad dude or because I've
like I just don't have morals short-term
thinking I was just short-term oriented
and I was I was afraid of failing I was
like you know so it was like okay
uh what can I do to like increase my
odds of winning
where he was just more confident he was
just like we're gonna win and we don't
need to
we don't need to play the game in any
way other than the the straight way to
win and like I hadn't really
internalized that but once I saw that
that was really sick to see because then
I was able to like adjust my knob and be
like oh yeah I'm just never gonna lie
like I just don't want to lie
even though my instinct was to
exaggerate or my instinct was to not
correct if somebody else believed
something about me that wasn't true
like whereas you know he would just he
was just totally comfortable in his own
skin so is he happier than me I would
say yes because he's more comfortable in
his own skin he's more comfortable with
where he's at he's more at peace with
where he's at he's not like at this like
inner inner fire or War to whatever not
at the same time I'm sure he misses like
the adventure and the thrill of like
building something and having it succeed
and having that mean something because
now no matter what he does like it's
very hard to have it mean something
unless it's just like intrinsic
motivation like I just love the product
or it's helping impact people but like
the thrill of winning is kind of gone
because he's already won it like such a
high school you know if you go to the
arcade machine and you set the high
score and it's so Out Of Reach you know
like okay you can play and have a good
game but like you're still gonna never
touch that high score again I think he
knows that you guys like launched two or
three things but the last thing was the
last thing was blab which I remember so
that's when we became friends when you
were one or two years into being the CEO
I think yeah uh and I was like what do
you do and you're like well we're
launching this thing and then you kept
jumping something and I would criticize
you I'm like dude you just gotta stick
to this one thing right but you're
probably right well who who knows yeah I
I now I I used to firmly believe that
was the way then I've seen some of the
things you've done and I've seen some of
the way some of our other friends have
done like there's tons of ways to get
things done
um what was the final thing that sold
the final thing that sold was we after
pivot after pivot pivot we got to a
thing that was like a Esports app so
basically Esports is like Trend where
people are playing video starting uh
it's like it's it's still just starting
it's like it was around but whatever but
it was really just starting I mean
twitch was like only six or seven years
old at the time no no this uh yeah I
guess I don't know twitch is around
twitch was big but it wasn't that wasn't
really the thing it was basically the
last idea we had the one that we got
acquired for we basically built an app
that was like the way a high schooler
could go and play you could sign up for
basketball or soccer or whatever like
some game you could go play in a league
for it and you would pay your league
dues and like there's little league
baseball and then there's like you know
AAU Sports there's all these youth
leagues Youth Sports is a big deal there
was no youth Esports that was the whole
idea and so we had had a bunch of
Technology we'd already been doing stuff
in streaming and gaming and so we took
all that Tech and we made an app that
let any high schooler sign up and play
in a fortnight League fortnite was the
big game at the time it was like
fortnite was ripping and there were more
people that played fortnite in the world
than played basketball and so we were
like that's crazy this has more players
but there's no organized League there's
only the pros there's no like amateurs
um and so we created the high school
fortnite league and we had an app that
you would sign up you'd make your team
you could invite friends and then you
would compete against other teams and
you get like ranked you playing
tournaments and all of it was streamed
which was cool because it turned it into
like a spectator sport how big did that
get
it was the biggest Esports league but it
was small overall we were only maybe
six or nine months into that version of
it it maybe had
10 to 25 000 players active players at
the time
um which was big because it like in
youth like you know in theory those
people would pay us like if you if I go
take my daughter's three and put her in
a soccer league I'm gonna pay 99 bucks
or whatever for her to be in that league
so same thing if we charge if we started
charging for it we could have this like
SAS business that was going to generate
I thought millions of dollars a year but
maybe tens probably never hundreds and
so that was the problem I was like oh if
we do this really well and we succeed at
this
um
it'll get to maybe like 10 million a
year maybe 20 million a year in Revenue
but never really beyond that and dude
isn't that [__] up that's not what we
signed up for it's not the way it sucks
it's not it doesn't suck because I agree
that that well that's just the game that
just sucks at that because it's not
enough yeah if you owned 100 of that you
could have made a sip maybe a
similar-ish amount of wealth as Michael
Birch yeah exactly uh you know but it
wasn't structured that way I know it
sucks and so once once I kind of got
that feeling and I was six or seven
years into the whole monkey Inferno
experiment with creating products with
that same team same group it was like
let's sell this and let's shake things
up you know I had I was lucky a friend
to leave like
like on the outside everything was
amazing office was amazing when I met
you product was cool you were like I'm
making 150 Grand a year and I'm like oh
my God you're like the wealthiest person
I've ever met it's like you have a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars a
year that's crazy and you're only in
your 20s I remember you told me that and
I was like shocked I was like and you
have this sick office like you're set
it felt that way at that time and over
time your expectations change you meet
other people who are doing better better
and you're like oh man hundreds I was
like 160 160. that's nothing like I'm
way underpaid and and in general I was
just like I just wanted to get a win I
don't think you're underpaid well for a
startup founder I wasn't underpaid but
if I just worked at a job right to
install the equity the equity was What
mattered and so
um I own 20 of that of that of of the
business and so anyways we decided to
sell and then that was you know
a crazy process and it's all
life-changing yeah for sure
um financially life-changing yeah
because go from no Millions to Millions
is you know that's life-changing and you
actually stayed there am so Amazon
bought the company and you stayed there
for two years right yeah would you and
are you happy you stayed
um
like I don't really think about the past
like what's like am I happy I saved yeah
sure like you know fine with it in
retrospect if I could go advise myself
now
I would have stayed only one year I
stayed two
um but I also got a bunch of other
benefits like I popped out two kids and
was able to like spend time with them
and didn't have to stress about yeah we
had like 10 months of paternity leave
what's that I mean you had like 10
months of paternity leave no actually
stupidly I only took two weeks with the
first kid what are you thinking
and I fell into all the traps you could
fall to I got a big it's like oh they
put me on this special project and the
CEO really loves it and cares now's the
critical time and and also being at home
honestly as a like you bring it home
harder than being at work so it's like
actually kind of easier to go back to
work in a way but like
I should have taken more time and I just
sort of like didn't and I think a lot of
employees fall into this trap into
companies they don't take that's like
the company has unlimited time off you
don't take it uh you could take this
much fraternity of maternity it's like
oh you feel pressure to cut it short
because you want to get back to your
team or your whatever stupid
um but the second year I was way more
chill and basically when did very little
work when did you start the Ecom thing
um somewhere around that time and you we
don't talk about it on purpose yeah and
so we won't talk about it much but what
do you want to say anything about it uh
it's a big business I think yeah I think
we'll start talking about it soon
um maybe that'll be you want to see how
big it is episode yeah it does like
15 million a year profitable damn dude
bootstrapped you told me you were doing
it and I was like why would you ever do
that and are you happy that you did that
or not
same thing in retrospect I would go
advise myself don't do this path because
you already had like clout a little bit
and now so during the sale of the first
company you started this podcast so then
that's when the hustle and this podcast
kind of collaborated but this podcast
people ask me how to grow a pot and I'm
like I don't know because Sean like
started doing it right away and it kind
of worked the day one like we got I
think the first episode was 60 000
downloads the first one was just hey
there's a new thing and people will go
check it out right yeah it still was a
good start but it got to a good start
and then when we switched it to this
format it got even better it like took
off in a better way and then just time
time like time is 63 years yeah and so
the thing I've learned so so why do I
say I would go back and do it
differently is because
I now realize something I already knew
but I didn't have the guts to act on
which was that at any given time you're
really only going to get to throw your
all into one thing
and so why not throw like if you're
gonna do that like choose really wisely
so for example
um when we got acquired by twitch I
didn't want to throw my all into that
um that wasn't like gonna be my my baby
my future was to be an employee at
twitch uh I wanted to earn out the deal
and I was feeling like I needed to
get that check right so there's like a
desperation to secure the bag
which by the way is the right move I
think maybe I think selling out is the
way to go I had asked a buddy who was
more successful at the time and I was
like what would you do if you were me
he's like I would quit on day one I was
like I would sell so that your team is
fine and your investors are happy then I
would quit on day one I go why like it's
so much money if I just stay even one
year one year no big deal and he's like
uh
he goes the surface area of opportunity
is too wide who said that truly and I'm
so smart man because I went I remember
we went for a walk and we walked for
like an hour and a half in the mission
we just walked back and forth through
the mission on the streets it was like
everything's closing missions ghetto as
hell and we were just like imagine like
pacing furiously we were doing that and
we were just talking through what's next
and I said I really want to do this
podcast I want to create a podcast he's
like a podcast I was like yeah I was
like I think if I could just be in a
million people's ear balls every morning
that's like that would be the most
fulfilling thing for me and it'd be
awesome 20 of the way there maybe yeah I
don't know a million is now I realize
like very aggressive of like every
morning but like you know if you just
keep going for five years it could
happen like that that's realistic now
but I remember thinking that's what I
want to do and I couldn't explain why I
was just sure I wanted to do it which in
retrospect is a really good signal like
that's the type of stuff you should go
do and I did that
um but then the other thing he was just
like yeah we just quit from day one the
surface area of opportunity wide and I
looked at it and like
uh and I was like well what would I do
if it wasn't this and he's like
again the surface area is so wide
anything and I was like give me an
example he goes all right I got a
company for you we could do right now
I'll co-found this with you anytime
we'll talk you into it because the silly
was all he had just sold an econ
business that he had just no no there's
a different idea not even the Ecom
business there's a different thing he
goes he goes any Commerce there's this
company called clavio they're uh email
sending companies are really taking off
he goes clavio for SMS and I go doesn't
claim you'll do SMS he goes no I'll go
one thing he goes yeah they probably
will uh aren't there these other
companies yeah sure but he's like you're
focusing on the wrong thing I'm telling
you I'm in Ecom
and SMS is like it's like email but
better people open it and he's like 90
seconds you just need a bit like if we
just build SMS for Ecom I think we can
go get like 100 brands that matter and
this would be a valuable company and I
was like okay it kind of sounds like I
don't know it was just like this idea it
was almost boring because it was like
here's a ready-made idea there was like
nothing else to think it was like
anything I said was basically a
distraction and he was right he was
absolutely right because uh so we talked
about it we went kind of down that
rabbit hole for like a little bit we
tried to find maybe a different operator
to come run it and then I see this
company in YC called PostScript
and I send it to him and I go hey this
is they're doing clavia for SMS he goes
all right I'm gonna invest so he goes
and him and his brother invested it and
PostScript is now like a multi-hundred
million dollar company in the same
there's the same period of time right so
like that was a path
sure maybe it wouldn't have worked out
for us but like I don't know I would
guess it probably would but like physics
has allowed it to happen and like
possible it played out and so whether
it's that one or even just the Ecom
thing if I just started it at day one
like the email makes more valuable than
what I earned out at twitch
um like it will be and so like again the
surface server opportunity was very wide
and I was one thing was a guarantee and
it was right in front of me everything
else was unknown and so I've learned now
that like you should just
keep going until you like go don't like
turn down a thing that's known if it's
not what you want if it's not the real
thing that you want
because only when you turn that down
then do you get the opportunity to go
find the thing you want it's like dating
right you're dating somebody who you
don't want to marry
but they're okay they're good it's just
not they're not the one and you might
try to talk yourself into it but like if
you're talking yourself into it you're
already losing and then like you gotta
you gotta break up in order to meet the
next person and like six or twelve I
forget when you started the milk Road
eight months ago
we launched in January yeah so so and
that's actually going really nicely you
have 150 to 250 000 subscribers yeah
over 200. wow okay and maybe you'll run
that forever maybe you'll sell who knows
have you ever thought about what you
want to do for the rest of your life
I think about that all the time I want
to brainstorm that with you okay what
would you like to do
well
um assuming that milk Road's not a thing
yeah assuming that milk grows not a
thing and assuming that uh the
e-commerce thing is not a thing so let's
assume two things right there because
in the spirit of what I'm talking about
um
if it's not the one then you gotta
find a different way so let's say let's
say that there's something else that's
the one what would it look like what
would it be like I
I think there's one version of it that's
like this podcast just more like like
what if this podcast if this podcast was
10 times bigger would I really care to
do anything else
financially 10 times bigger
uh either way audience I think well is
there translates to money so is there a
is there an amount of money like whether
money is important or not it is kind of
you have I think you should work
backwards from that yeah is there an
amount of money that you'd want per year
the target currently is 50. in net worth
yeah total net worth uh that's not like
in tied up in one company that's like
can can die next month like
in of you know assets you own kind of
like liquid you know but it could be a
little bit more like loanable against
yeah like not concentrated into one
paper valuation but a podcast would more
so be a or a media company for you would
be more so an annual income thing I
would imagine so it could stack up to 50
or it could just wait and then sell for
50 or or net 50 in the end in some way
well I think that you so and by the way
50 is just a random number you just made
it up yeah so it's a lot maybe we should
start there
maybe that's the wrong number no maybe
that's a good number I know what you
like you like nice [__] you like
spending a lot of stuff I think 50 is a
good number for you okay I think the the
difference between 30 and 50
for you or me is actually not a
significant amount but shoot for 50 then
I think that's a good number the
difference between anything above 100 is
enough today that you would really
really have to work hard like you'd have
to be you'd purposely have to be a
jackass to go through it that's mostly
true for 50 10 you can go through you
know that's just like a big house and
like a medical emergency and like you
can like kind of blow through that a bad
investment yeah I mean it is you know I
mean and you can go and you do a lawsuit
yeah two or three like pretty quickly 30
is in the range of where it's enough
that like you can't screw it up 100 for
sure like you're you're you would have
to have like some Crooks around you or a
like a stupid like your dad's smart
enough to be like hey man
um can we have it can we talk about this
uh I think you're going too hard you
don't need a Lamborghini yet uh you know
what I mean buffalo buffalo time
um
so anyway hot one we'll do a hot one
dude yeah we're talking money now 50 50
is enough I think that's a good goal but
and I think that I've seen you grow to
be this like Tech person to a media
person you are better at media than you
are Tech I believe that you are better
at investing than you are at running
things I believe you're better at
starting things than you are running
things and you are horrible at managing
like I I don't theoretically at managing
50 plus people
yeah I don't even know I think you'd be
awesome at leading them but horrible at
managing them just don't want to
um yeah but you're really good at being
like a leader I bet you'd actually be a
really good CEO too I think you'd be a
horrible there's like what like
inspirational speeches yeah you're
you're naturally inspired like what
Jerry Jerry Seinfeld said comedy is like
a secret weapon that most people
understand
comedy is kind of in storytelling just
Charisma the ability to capture
someone's like imagination and make them
believe something or or capture emotion
from them
or make them feel certain emotion you
definitely have that you have that you
everyone a lot of people ask me like
well Sean always good at this I'm like
yeah he was actually always good at it
and then he's gotten better so I think
that you you have that so I would say
you could be a CEO but you're you
actually got really lucky and Ben Levy
doesn't publicly get enough credit but
that's like your partner and all these
things yeah he 100 is your yang to the
Yang and if I was you I would go way
harder on that partnership with him and
potentially launch more things
um and
let him operate who's having the most
fun like who's got the who's having the
most fun with uh I mean you with their
life stuff you are doing pretty good
okay besides me who else
um
Rob Dyrdek was pretty amazing I think
that like like you're more of a Rob
Dyrdek than you are Mark Zuckerberg
that's for sure you know what I mean
like if it like just like one guy one
company hardcore Tech versus like little
here little there a little here all
based around like a personality yeah you
know
um
what is like okay you exited recently
you had to think about what you're gonna
do next yeah how did you think about it
when I I actually gave this advice to
someone so what I did I sold so I sold
for enough that
um you don't have to do anything I don't
have to do anything not enough that like
I'm gonna go and buy crazy enough that I
still am ambitious but enough that like
a a fairly luxury level of needs are met
forever and when I did I did that and I
realized okay for the next 12 months but
it could be longer All I'm gonna do is
research and think and I never give
anyone that advice because I say you
just gotta start and do stuff and by the
end of this weekend like have something
live but I'm like no I already I know I
do that I I have that ability so for the
next 12 months or however long I'm gonna
feel this sounds like I'm [__] Oprah
I'm gonna be not guilty about like yeah
this is so Oprah there's like some
movies is that actually from Oprah no
but I just it sounds like it because
like you feel guilty not doing [__]
you're like oh I'm missing out I'm
missing out I'm like no this is like
really Oprah I'm gonna I'm gonna let I'm
gonna forgive myself yeah yeah like this
I sound like I need one of those
Coachella hats that chicks wear uh like
I I was like I'm just not gonna be
guilty about doing stuff I'm just gonna
research and I'm gonna read and when the
feeling feels right it's gonna feel
right and I'm gonna go all in but until
then I'm not gonna I'm not gonna say
maybe this stuff I'm not gonna say yes
to anything I'm gonna say no to
everything I'm just not gonna I'm just
not gonna worry about it right and I
just read and I researched and I think
that
I actually think you suck at sitting
still
yeah that's why I gotta I gotta do it
and forgive myself give myself Grace
yeah I have Grace for myself but you
have to you gotta chill because like
someone like you you can execute
like you you already you can do stuff
right but then okay so you chill you
read you do other stuff talk to people
and you talk to people you enter I mean
ideas come up the business that I'm
talking about the business that I end up
doing now I interviewed them on the Pod
like multiple I was like I'm just gonna
talk to you like I got that go and
interview people so
so you do that but how did you resist
the temptation to okay how many ideas
did you have before this one none that
you were none you weren't tempted to do
anything before that no no I no I was
not this was the first idea that you
were like I'm gonna do it and then you
just did it it was the first one that I
felt okay I did investing so I did Angel
Investing I realized that's stupid and I
hate it I hate Angel Investing you're
good at it and you love it I think I'm
only good at it because I'm popular but
I don't like I don't like it uh and I
hate it it's so boring okay dude it's so
stupid so I did that and we invested 15
million dollars in one year into
70 companies and so I kind of like went
fast on that and then I realized uh-uh
I'm out I hate this so I bailed uh and
so I like tinkered with that but that
wasn't like a full-time thing we only
worked on that 10 hours a week yeah
so anyway
um I do I just read like crazy and
talked to people
I think you should do that why wouldn't
you just take like 18 months and just
like that is my plan not 18 but like
just however long 12. uh basically it's
like let's take 12. listen here this is
this analogy or this visualization will
help imagine your life is this line all
right you're about a third of the way
through maybe 25 of the way maybe if we
live a long time
this amount of time this like one inch
on this 15 inch segment just one inch of
time can was going to impact the rest of
the 10 inches do you know what I'm
saying it changes the color it changes
the entire trajectory so why not spend
like a ton of time early on right really
focusing instead of because
there's a chance that had you done that
previously which you didn't have the
luxury to but had you done that
previously or maybe you did have the
luxury too it would have made better
decision you would have made better
decisions and you would have gone all in
on one thing which have cumulatively
made more than all the other stuff
combined right and so the question then
is the fear I have is
how do I make sure that's not just a
kind of like like sort of like a How
will I know it's also
um how do I do it in a way that's not
just absolutely mandaring or maybe
that's all right maybe it is supposed to
be Meandering I think that's all right
because that's not your personality and
so just by Meandering like it it's
almost like it's almost like most people
we have to tell them that hit on the gas
harder with you you're a car who's back
wheels we lift it up and you're already
going all the way as hard as you can and
all we're going to be doing is just
figuring out which direction we're going
to place that car and then when we're
ready we're gonna drop it that's a good
analogy do you know what I mean yeah
most people we gotta feel cool too well
like a really fast car well like most
people we have to like fuel that car and
like no go harder good you're good like
all right you're already moving a little
bit now go leaving harder with you it's
like no dude that gas is down already
right like we might as well just find
out the right place to put it then we
put it you're going all in yeah that's
exactly so that's how I would look at it
all right like people who are who are
who's oven burn Hots when I say like
they're going to be burning [__] it's
just like pick the right thing yeah like
you know what I'm saying remember I made
a joke that people made fun of me but I
actually saw it from The Departed
they're like John Lennon give him a
[__] tuba and he's gonna make art
that's what he does
whatever our stupid industry is it's
like I don't know man just like give me
a computer get out of the way and I can
figure out how to like be cool but not
be cool but like make something at least
somewhat intriguing because that's just
what I love doing and I think the same
100 with you
all right I like that that's good right
what yeah I like it so
the last podcast you have me 100
convinced that AI is the thing so I
would go into AI
yeah that could be it I just think that
that's like the huge pawn and you just
cast anywhere out in that pond and
you're gonna have a winner yeah that's
fair you think so
um it seems that way at the moment but I
think it's more like if it's like if I
was gonna manage or wander around I'm
definitely spending some time in that
neighborhood to see what's up I'm trying
all the difference and it's still early
and I'm asking people where the best
tacos are I'm talking to people and
being like what was here before this and
that's that's what I would do in that
space before right just dude it's still
early enough to you could take time like
you take your time you could take six to
12 months off and just relax I talked to
someone the other day who works at open
AI and I was like you're and this guy's
like a little bit naturally of a
pessimist like he's like not he doesn't
just believe in hype uh and I was like
hey is this legit and he goes yeah it's
legit I was like should I do I have to
be worried that it's gonna like take
over the world he's like no
I don't know when that will happen or
even if it will happen because we are a
bit away but like in terms of just like
replacing like developers jobs or
um just like making life easier and like
just like for art making new types of
art it's 100 legit and it's almost here
it's basically here right and so I think
that's like that stuff's pretty amazing
should we do a hot one yeah I guess all
right let's try it how hot is it I don't
know I've never tried these before I
don't want to get like a panic attack
where's this place that'll make a good
thumbnail though
where's this place from I don't know I
doordashed it
is it hot no it's not hot maybe this is
not the hot one let's see no
I don't think so this I think this is
supposed to be the hot one but
uh
that's not hot right no this one's
hotter I don't want to eat like a a ton
of it and for it to like kick in yeah
yeah yeah
it's like it's not hot
I don't think it's bad
at all yeah I think you got that yeah
it's all right tastes good though Rick
Ross probably owns this Wing Place does
he have a wing place yeah you know it's
like 30 Wing Stops you know he's like
the rap version of Shaq you know I'm
saying like he owns like five guys and
[__] should we just do that on like 30
Wing Stops no dude so I've been in the
Airbnb in like real estate game it's
that's whack too I thought that was dope
it's whack it's just it takes too long
it's just too slow like I I will come up
with an idea and want to do something
and like you don't get results if you're
building something for 18 months 24
months right or with like a rental uh
like let's do this this and this and
like I don't know if it's any cool for
three months or if it's like you know if
it's actually a good idea no I think
real estate's stupid I think it's really
cool to invest in but like as a creative
person
it's whack yeah it's like no dopamine
Rush either yeah when people are like oh
buy boring businesses invest in boring
businesses
it's in the name yeah also in the name
guys yeah like where's the buy exciting
businesses
yeah they talk about buying businesses
like bro what you want is something
that's boring to other people but not
boring to you if it's also boring to you
like ah come on you wasted your talent I
don't want boring life exactly I see
that stuff too I'm like man I don't want
and I don't want to work with a guy who
runs a dry cleaning company I just like
I you know I'll be like
sitting outside on the corner like King
of the Hill like yep like I don't want
to have that conversation
you know what I mean I don't want to
talk about it yeah I want to like do
stuff
um yeah these are all right that's not
hot though is it yeah
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most trms are cobbled
together
to adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better
um where do we want to go with this
episode
uh I don't know what would make it
interesting spelled by the way oh thank
you you want to finish with like a rapid
fire
Hot Seat questions yeah
that I think that's a hot one this one
right this one's hotter
um that one actually is hot for me there
we go the milk is coming into play
that was hot all right let me dip this
one oh this is almond milk by the way
hmm
yeah
all right what's the rapid fire
um all right let me think of a couple
questions all right hot seat question uh
here's number one
would you rather be
three times as famous and half as rich
as you are today
or stay as you are
stay as I am
why
I'm married being famous Isn't that cool
I mean what's up like single people yeah
what what advantage does Fame have at
this point I mean some people put my ego
but like I some people just feels good
and then also uh you could argue that if
you were three times more famous you
could actually earn a bunch more too so
you know it could make other things
easier I'd rather be
two times as rich
twice as funny
and half is ripped or twice as ripped
and half as funny being funnier is
better for for like picking up girls and
having guy friends probably so well
funny
are you trying to pick up girls I send
me guys too
I know being rip seems to do it too
dude being funny is better being funny
is way better would you rather be funny
I'm all in on what about uh the fame or
wealth being half as funny that would be
like that'd be really sad like you could
be half as
fit
and you can kind of recover if you're
having this funny there's just no
recovering from that that's like the end
of the game for you and you are you were
half as fit three years ago and you were
doing fine yeah exactly I've been there
before yeah hello my old friend
nice to see you again what uh what about
the other one
um tell me a story what's the highest
Stakes negotiation you've ever been in
selling the company what about you well
when did it feel high stakes for you was
there every moment day I'm almost
positive every single day there's a
chance I can kill the deal uh the
HubSpot CEO
did I tell you this no you know he got
into a oh the car there's a skiing
accident the day after right it was even
worse Brian was on the Podge he told you
about it uh he him and his son were
snowmobiling in Vermont or wherever
people snowmobile I don't [__] know
and like his son hit the gas instead of
the break and they ran into his dad
Brian
and they fall over a cliff and it was
either like 12 or 24 hours that he just
sat there he's like and he said goodbye
to his son and he's like you know might
be it yeah this is it and suddenly they
get cell phone service and someone comes
and finds them and then afterwards he
comes back and close the deal
did you text Sam today yeah
one more thing
that happened two weeks after the deal
closed and like I think that company is
big enough that him like
frankly didn't want to put a pause on
yeah I don't know if that would have
like I don't know hey guys not to be
insensitive just wanted to check in if
we're still on for the whole
Exposition the R.I.P bride but uh so uh
sending out the DocuSign yeah
so that I mean totally understand if you
need a day yeah so
anything could have killed it no no pun
intended anything
I'll do respect Brian I love Brian uh so
I'm only joking but uh any anything
could have like destroyed that deal and
I think that is stressful so that was
the highest one what was yours well I
have two one was I think did I tell the
auction story when we bought the bibo
brand back that tells the story before
uh so Michael tells me at one point he
goes hey we have an opportunity to buy
bibo oh yeah and you had to go like
looking like a schmuck so no one knew
who you were
this is how I look
thanks though
but the we go to a courthouse basically
so so he tells you we're gonna buy it
back and we uh and my mind I'm like
awesome
what are we gonna do with it and he's
like I don't know we got to figure
something out he's like it's a good
domain you get the email list you get
the domain you get the hardware and you
get like the legal ownership of that
Hardware like whatever servers or
whatever they had so um and so we were
like okay what is this worth and so we
came up with like we sat in this room
trying to speculate and then Michael
just like put down the hammer at one
point he's like I don't think
we're gonna be able to buy it for less
than a million and I don't think I
really want to pay much more than a
million so let's do it with a million
that's your bid so we fly to LA
it's me our lawyer and our CEO and we
get to a courthouse and I'm like is that
a courthouse what are we gonna do stay
in front of a judge like and the judge
goes okay are there multiple bit
multiple parties here to buy it out of
bankruptcy
um yeah and then and we don't know who
else is going to be there we don't know
if anyone else is going to be there and
there's two other groups that raise
their hand and they say she's like all
right go to that room and you're gonna
auction against each other to see who
wins
I was like what can we go to this tiny
room I'm just gonna fight and yeah
basically and one person it's like a rap
god one out one person from each team
got to sit at the table everybody else
was behind them like oh and so then it's
us and then it's Match.com and it's uh
some other social media.com well like
IAC they own a bunch of internet
properties so they wanted it but it's
kind of like vulturing yeah they were
like we're gonna harvest the profiles
and use them for dating it's like what
like the SEO we need that SEO juice like
damn I hope you guys don't win that
sounds awful
um were the people kind of one another
or were they like you you just sit down
and it's like bid and we're like oh here
I'm the representative from this this
and this all right so it starts and it's
like we'll start the bidding at 100 000
and then it'll go up by 50 000
increments
um
up to 500 000 and then it'll just be
free form after that we'll be here as
long as it takes to finish the bid and
you get like a minute in between or you
get like a minute between a minute or
two minutes or something like that in
between bids to decide if you're gonna
bid
And So It Goes 100 150 200 250 so on so
forth goes up to 700 000 and then the
guy one guy drops out so then it's just
us and match
he calls time out
he's like we need to go make a phone
call right before seven dude that's like
getting in a fight with someone and
being like time out
it's exactly what happened he got
punched in the nose and it's like time
out so we're at 750 000. and they go
outside they have to make a phone call
to their boss and I was like oh
my son having a boss yeah you like
tattled on them you're like uh sir is
that so I try to go eavesdrop I walk
outside they immediately stop talking I
just go to the restroom twice just to
see if I can pick up anything and then
and I come back in I'm like I talked to
our lawyer I was like okay they're
calling at 750 000 they're probably
getting authorization to go up that was
probably their max they're probably
getting authorization probably the
highest they can go is a million
um and I told the like Auctioneer person
I was like no more timeouts like that
can't we can't do that again and so she
they come back in and she's like there's
no more timeouts I'm like okay cool the
pressure's on them now and bidding goes
800 850 900
950. when you are going when you make
your bid for 900 you say like oh well
that's the thing so we had been acting
like that to be are you kidding me guys
and then then I told the lawyer between
like I built this thing I know it's not
worth that I go
I go we gotta just act like we have an
infinite bankroll so that they just feel
like they can't win this auction and so
I said as soon as they say a number just
top it immediately top it with no
hesitation just like not like we're here
all day I'm I could say I could I could
go on and on and on and so that's what
she did she changed up her demeanor
started doing that and basically we got
to a million and at a million she pulls
a great move she doesn't say a million
she goes one million 25 000.
to just up it and then you know that
they were all were stopping a million we
knew they had gotten authorization for a
round number so I think it was actually
1 million and ten I think she did she
did 10 000 above and they just go you
guys can have it you guys can take care
of it and they were like yeah our Max
was a million
I was like yeah
and so we got it and then we like okay
but that was like the most high stakes
like hand of Poker I've ever been
involved in basically
um
all right we'll do we'll do one more
um I can't read it from back here what
were the questions that you told me uh
another one was like what is the um
I don't know like what's the oh so
something that you thought you were onto
something but it turned out to be
totally wrong yeah you thought you were
on something you turned what's yours
we had one when uh building blab
basically like when we built blab it
looked like it was taking off and this
was now like four years in
and imagine you're four years in and you
feel like you might have just like made
the next big like basically what
Clubhouse and it became that's what blab
was and we started seeing this like
rapid growth and people loved it and
everybody felt it was new and fresh
everything else we had made people like
oh this is just like Snapchat no matter
what we did they're like it's kind of
like Snapchat
and we're like God damn it like the next
thing we build is not gonna be like
Snapchat no matter what that was blab
and it takes off to 200 000 users pretty
quickly it gets to a million users and
VC you know Founders fund wants to
invest and all this stuff and it felt
like
we did it like this is going to be the
next social thing and we own it like we
are actually going to own one of those
things
and then it got to about 4 million and
then it sort of just we started to
realize why isn't the number going up as
much it's like I don't know sign ups are
still up it's like oh it's super leaky
the retention like the retention has
been getting worse and worse it started
out okay and now it's just pretty bad
and this was all the span of life and
it's like an impossible problem to solve
too it's not like like even if you
operate at a plus level it's just like a
retention is like the pro retention is a
thing that's worth anything in business
and retention is the thing that's also
the hardest to solve because like it's
like dating like you if you wanted to
pick up somebody that's like just
getting users like you could change the
way you look you could teach your two
pickup lines and like get on in the
keeper yeah get you some you know a
shirt that fits you a little bit better
and like you know want to pick the
booger out of your nose you can get that
you can go get their number
but you can't make them date you you
can't make him marry you and like that's
what retention is it's like are they
going to marry your product or not and
so once I knew that was a problem I was
like oh God we tried so many things to
try to fix it and it was just like not
not moving because it's more fundamental
it's like is this something people want
to do all the time or not
and it's very hard to like spam them
with notifications to try to get that
number up so the year we sold the hustle
you know we sold in February so we set a
whole year ahead of us but I think we
probably would have done around 20
million in sales and
I started the company wanting to hit 100
million in Revenue before year 10. and
we sold it between four and five I think
year four and five
so we were kind of on track we would
have got there yeah probably we could
have maybe could have gotten there and I
knew I could like I started the company
with just an email even though people
said it's stupid because I was like I
remember telling you stupid I was like
do video dude do Facebook videos yeah
but I was like Snapchat Instagram the
math is such that like I'm pretty sure
that like
you know people are kind of dismissing
this as like a hobby but look if you
like just change a 10 000 person email
list to like 5 million like the numbers
add up to 100 million dollars
uh no one's real I don't know anyone
who's ever done that but I'm pretty sure
that could happen like I understand the
math and like each seller of advertising
would sell 1.5 million dollars of ads
and they're already people that do that
so if I just hire like you know 100 of
them like things add up like this could
all work out fine actually but I didn't
truly believe my own prediction even
though I knew like this list lines up
yeah you could tell everybody else but
yeah telling yourself in your head is
different I was like this works actually
this works and I didn't entirely believe
it and so I sold right when I got like a
pretty decent offer because I wanted to
secure the bag but in reality I made a
mistake I didn't make a mistake because
I actually would have did the same thing
again but I could have achieved my goal
right now looking back at it I know
morning Brew's kind of doing that right
there 500 million something like that
well they're at um
they're probably 80 million in sales
yeah so they're close so they're like
getting close and and I knew and him and
I Austin are good friends now and we
both talk I'm like he's like yeah you
guys actually would have been there like
they're a year older than us in terms of
company so like you guys actually would
have been there even better because you
had subscription Revenue
and he was like you're and he's he was
like I'm actually amazing at operating
things but you guys are always way
better at like inventing your [__] and
we would just copy you and uh or you
know he said something like that and uh
he is really good at operating though um
and uh I uh that was my biggest mistake
[Music]
foreign